foreign
the show that lifts you up for at least
the next 30 minutes you and me as well
says here we got a great cast of
characters among them these a man who
overcame the odds to return to his
favorite sport after losing his vision
we'll tell you how he got back on the
skateboard also a puppy who joined the
New York Mets what's a dog doing with a
major league baseball team we'll explain
also a team with autism who loves
musical theater gets a surprise of a
lifetime in Times Square and the band
that meets every week on the same corner
of Minneapolis what's the powerful
reason behind the group we'll get into
it and a family displaced by a hurricane
receives devastating news but there is a
teen in their neighborhood who only
wants to help what he did to give them a
boost all that plus our heartwarming
videos the ones you just gotta see you
know what you're watching it's the
uplift morning
[Music]
welcome welcome to the uplift I'm Tony
decopo I'm your host we do have a great
show for you and we are going to start
with a story about a skateboarder who
overcame the odds to get back on the
board after he lost his sight
here's Caitlin O'Kane with his story
Justin Bishop has been skating since he
was 10 years old but took a break for
about three years when he lost his
vision he was born with retinitis
Pigmentosa at the age of 25 when I lost
my sight and I lost all confidence in
myself because you know I went from
being able to
in uh travel independently to feeling
isolated and stuck
he knew he would eventually lose his
vision but nothing could prepare him for
what that was like
Justin had to First relearn how to live
independently like getting the mail and
taking the bus to the grocery store but
he wanted to do more so he started
re-learning how to skateboard
well when you're blind it's not like
learning how to do a kickflip it's more
of I want to be able to
do this trick off this ramp now how can
I get to point A to point B and so you
know with that sometimes that's beachy
devices I have a little uh audible
markers I use to help me get from one
spot to the next I have rope if I need
exact precision and it's a lot of
spatial awareness walking the course
before you skate it to know everything
what's going on
after reconnecting with his passion
Justin became a professional
skateboarder and he competes in adaptive
skateboarding events in retrospect I
wish I never gave up skateboarding
um because I would have had at least a
staple in my life that even though when
I lost my sight I was horrible at
skateboarding because I had to really
learn balance
um without seeing and doing all that but
at least I had something that I loved to
work hard at he says skateboarding can
teach anyone a valuable lesson things
worth doing are going to be hard without
skateboarding I don't think I would have
gone through my transition of blindness
as easy as I did you know I mean
don't get me wrong it was one of the
hardest three years of my life to kind
of return to who I am mentally identity
wise and feeling independent but having
skateboarding for a majority of my life
before I lost my eyesight taught me that
discipline I needed to
to learn something new you fail you fail
you fail and skateboarding taught me if
you fail enough times you're gonna learn
how to do it right
a truly amazing story Caitlin O'Kane
bringing it to start us off thank you
Caitlin moving on now to Betty Reid
soskin she had many accomplishments
during her 101 years on this planet most
notably she became the oldest park
ranger in the nation working at the
Rosie the Riveter National Historical
Park
CBS San Francisco is Rick villaroman has
more on this history-making Ranger
with all the Fanfare of a royal visit
Betty Reid soskin was greeted by the
students of the school that was renamed
after her just one year ago
and why not at 101 she's earned every
bit of Accolade she gets after a career
that spanned decades
but she still can't believe it I just
can't imagine that that's me
just not possible Betty started her
career as a park ranger at the age of
85. giving history lessons about the
women who worked in factories during
wartime technically she retired earlier
this year but shows no signs of slowing
down I never didn't really retire I'm
still working I don't know if I'll ever
read the retire hello today she met with
students in the classroom answered
questions so who in here has a question
for a 101 year old woman and what's
visiting a middle school without can we
take a selfie yes but she's smart enough
to know that there are still lessons for
a 101 year old
oh I learned about about kinetic energy
I didn't realize
there was such a thing
I'm going to have to look it up she need
look no further than a mirror because as
far as energy goes she's got it to spare
her daughter diara put it this way I
truly have been blessed to be able to
have you know a front row seat and to
watch her in action as far as lessons to
give after celebrating 101 birthdays she
offered this have you kind of figured
out which is the best birthday cake
flavor yes and which is it's the white
cake it's the one that Costco sells
who can argue with that and with so many
stories to tell and so many lives
touched
when I asked if her biggest Legacy will
be being a park ranger no it's happening
this is cool this has been
most wonderful thing this has happened
to me because I know
that I mattered
and to so many matter she does
my whole life has been leading to this
moment I've never dreamed that it would
I would trust her cake recommendation
that's a great story as well and we got
more of them coming up including a team
with autism and a love for musical
theater getting a big big surprise that
has to do with her favorite Broadway
musical plus meet another team who found
a way to help a family in need by doing
what he loves what's that we'll tell you
foreign
videos ones you just gotta see we're
gonna start with this one
take a look there at U.S army Captain
Harold ramming hiding in a hospital room
his wife was expecting their first child
and knew she might have to give birth
without him because he was deployed in
Iraq well fortunately he made it back to
Illinois right on time even though his
wife went into labor early she had no
clue he was there to surprise her and as
you can see she was overwhelmed with
emotion to see him there
just hours before they welcomed their
son Harold Leroy Raymond II
oh it's a sweet story to our next video
another emotional one taking an
eight-year-old Titan Weekly's birthday
party he was given a big box and his
friends helped him open it only to find
another box and inside that box another
box and then another you see where this
is going eventually he got to the real
gift also in a box but it brought tears
to his eyes it was a box with an iPhone
inside he had been wanting one for a
very long time and his parents surprised
him
it was exactly what he was looking for
very very well received and we're told
by Mom and Dad very well deserved all
right take a look at this video showing
16 year old football player Samuel
Harris talking to his teammates about
his mom you know somebody in my family
that I respect is easily like there's a
lot of people but I was in my mom
because she's been gone for about a year
in the military and she's gonna continue
to work hard
she's just a hard worker
Samuel there is like hey I'm talking
here wait a minute I know her that's his
mom she deployed overseas in January I
came home to describe to surprise him in
the middle of his speech and when asked
uh now whether she'd be home for a while
he said well I hope she will be I hope
so we all hope so
congrats on that reunion all right
coming up why does this band this one
right here meet up every Monday on one
particular Street Corner in Minneapolis
we'll tell you the powerful reason why
that group exists and the Hollywood sign
it's hitting a big milestone and getting
a big makeover too what's happening to
that iconic Landmark we will show you
right after the break
[Music]
when you think of Hollywood you probably
think of the movies but also of that
very famous sign the Hollywood Sign
tucked into the hills well that Landmark
is reaching a major Milestone this year
and to celebrate it is getting a
makeover here's Carter Evans with more
there's nothing more Hollywood than an
icon marking its 100th anniversary by
getting some work done
dangling from the 45-foot letters
painters are giving the sign its first
makeover in 10 years and to see it up
close we had to hike down to it this is
like getting into one of the most
exclusive clubs in Los Angeles nobody
gets to go to the Hollywood Sign
security at this place is really tight
we have cameras all over the place you
know Jeff serenom chairs the Hollywood
Sign trust that pays for its upkeep
recently they uncovered a new discovery
at the base of the letters hidden for 40
years there's two places in Hollywood
where you can see hand prints and
signatures in concrete one is at the
Chinese Theater and the other one is up
here a tribute from the workers that
built the Hollywood star that now draws
crowds from around the world it's hard
to believe that that sun in some way or
form has been there for almost 100 years
I know yeah definitely it's held out
well hasn't it
when it first premiered in 1923 the sign
was an advertisement for the ritzy real
estate development below it
hollywoodland but the wooden letters
were never meant to last much more than
a year and it showed the word land was
removed in 1949 and the Hollywood sign
became a shining emblem of the
entertainment industry but over the
years the wear and tear reflected a city
in Decline the new quarter of a million
dollar Hollywood sign in 1978 the new
sign was reborn and rebuilt with the
concrete and steel that still keeps it
standing today the Hollywood sign is a
special place it has to be protected
otherwise we'll have taggers up here and
you know doing all kinds of Mischief not
that it hasn't been done
pranksters have hijacked the Hollywood
Sign more than a few times other planned
Transformations marked the BET Awards
and the LA Rams Super Bowl win oh oh my
God and with the magic of Hollywood it's
been destroyed on TV and in movies again
and again and again
the work here now ensures the real sign
will continue to shine on this
star-studded city for years to come it's
so important to the city of La and and
all of its people but to the world it's
almost like meeting a celebrity
you know what the Hollywood sign is a
celebrity and it deserves its own star
on the Walk of Fame maybe for the next
big birthday Carter Evans CBS News Los
Angeles
moving on now to a 19 year old with
autism who loves musical theater and one
show in particular stands out to her
it's an inspiring message made an impact
on her life here's Natasha lorno with
that story
Broadway shows can open your eyes to new
worlds or show you you're not alone in
yours for reality diabru the show that
strikes a chord is wicked when I was Age
Two
I was diagnosed with autism
and it was still early on people still
didn't know that much about autism so
the worst was assumed about me in the
worst assumptions were made about me my
mom was told that I would never learn to
speak my mum was told that I was never
going to
learn to use the bathroom I was never
going to learn to walk
she learned all these horrific things
when she saw Wicked in London she felt
an inspiration by the end of Act One
Defying Gravity my mother had gained
inspiration
prove those assumptions wrong about
that have been made about me Rihanna saw
Wicked herself the themes of friendship
standing up for what's good and finding
yourself made an impact
and like the characters in the show she
has defied gravity
she's now a student at the American
Musical and dramatic Academy the theater
lover recently entered a contest by
Prudential and playbill to win Broadway
tickets and when she won she of course
chose to see her favorite musical now
starring Brittany Johnson who is making
history as the first black woman to Star
as Glinda full time what she'd asked me
was seeing Brittany Johnson at Belinda
for the first time that I never seen her
and that was one of the main reasons why
I've chosen Wicked specifically
uh pull that giveaway as part of the
contest riala went to Times Square to
give an interview she thought she was
there to talk about the ticket giveaway
but she was in for a big surprise to
meet Brittany Johnson I think would be
very fashioned very inspirational I
would
right next to you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wicked has inspired riala for years but
she's never quite seen Glinda like this
and she hopes to one day follow in
Brittany's footsteps as a Broadway star
my biggest piece of advice is to
remember that you are what make you
unique so it's not about trying to be
anything for anyone else when you walk
into an audition room when you walk into
any situation you are what makes you
unique
so make sure to just be yourself you're
enough
[Music]
you are enough good advice for all of us
all right more than a year ago a group
of performers started meeting up on the
very stream same street corner in
Minneapolis and they did it every week
week after week after week they haven't
missed a Monday since that first meeting
CBS Minnesota's Carolyn [ __ ] shows us
now why that group performed in the
first place
On Any Given Monday are we warm at this
corner of 38th going in Chicago
we can't get over here you'll find the
community
[Music]
[Applause]
concert just bring your horn
same time
[Music]
same place
same Mission
there are so many people that saw George
Floyd's murder and said what do I do I
don't know what to do
[Music]
a lot of us as musicians felt we could
use our art and use our gifts to to
bring as an offering to the space and to
the movement a movement for racial
Justice Butchy Austin felt was worth
playing his trumpet for soon he found
others performing with the same purpose
I thought I would just start playing and
then I did play for a minute and then I
was approached by some other musicians
in the Square at the same time that's
sort of how we started praying together
some starting as strangers I didn't know
any of those players but eventually
friends
who together became brass solidarity we
want to be part of the call for justice
and we want to also contribute good
feelings to the community for 81 weeks
they haven't missed a Monday you put
smiles on people's faces and let you
know they care and it and it fills your
soul so that's why I do it a show they
believe Must Go On
music unites coming up meet a member of
the New York Mets a new one he's not
there to play baseball but he is there
to learn
what's his role we'll tell you there he
is plus they were displaced by a
hurricane and then they found out their
baby had cancer wow uh when one teen in
the neighborhood heard that story he
decided to come to their aid and he came
up with a very creative way to help find
out what he did after the break
thank you
the New York Mets have a new team member
named Shea but he is not training for
baseball he's there to learn another job
here's Nancy Chen
here at Citi Field home of the New York
Mets there are plenty of star players
this is Shea he's a service dog in
training but few are as obsessed with
the ball as this good boy in a first for
Major League Baseball the Mets
charitable Foundation teamed with
America's vet dogs to sponsor Shea the
nine-month-old lab will eventually be
matched with a first responder or
military veteran at no cost what is the
importance of training Shea in a place
like this he is learning you know
socialization skills interacting with
the crowd interacting with the players
on the field and ultimately that'll help
make him a better service dog he is
absolutely my best friend Air Force
veteran Nathan Gardner got Kenzo in
February it's been life-changing knowing
that I'm not alone anymore and taking me
out of that Despair and getting me
strength and helping me find myself
again good boy Shea will continue with
the Mets through spring training next
year he could change someone's life he
will change somebody's life steady a
winning Play All Around good boy Nancy
Chen CBS News New York
it's a good boy all right our next and
final story is about a teenage boy who
heard about a family in his neighborhood
a family that needed a boost in a big
way and he came up with a very creative
way to help them here's Caitlin O'Kane
again with his story
when hurricane Ida hit Louisiana last
year the Estevez family's home was
destroyed as they began to rebuild their
lives they were gutted again their
nine-month-old daughter Blakely had
cancer
I mean it was the worst news we we could
ever hear obviously hearing your child
has cancer is not easy and it's just
like almost like what else can go wrong
you know it's just another thing
happening
need of a home the Estevez has moved
into a family member's house on their
new Street lived a high school swimmer
named Drew Lonnie
Drew heard about the new family in his
neighborhood displaced by a hurricane
and he learned that their baby had
cancer he was compelled to help so I
decided to swim for Blakely doing the
thing that I know how to do Drew and his
teammates from Holy Cross High School
held a lapse for Blakely event raising
money by having members of the community
sponsor each swimmer we both were in a
grandson like the Young Generation has
hope after all his kids doing this all
on his own and uh I know I said I'll be
there no matter what to make sure I'm
supporting Drew
but I don't know if he expected it or
what when I showed up there were a lot
of people there A lot more people
swimming than I expected I really
thought it was just drew they swam 200
laps and raised 14
000 for the Estevez family you know
admittedly had a little doubt and a high
school kid just swimming laps to raise
money for Blakely they told me his goal
was 500 and I was like that's great
hopefully he makes it
um
but I guess
you know obviously we feel grateful and
we're thankful for Drew but for everyone
else out there who hears the story or
read reads about it
made me realize they don't ever think
you're too small or you can't do it
alone or you know if you just take the
first step towards doing something you
may be surprised how many people step up
and help and you never know your goal
might be 500 and you walk away raising
14 000 in one morning just before the
Epic swim meet the Estevez has got to
move back into their home and in August
this year Blakely completed chemo Drew
didn't know how helpful he could be but
he's glad he dove in to try yes a 15
year old boy can do it anyway be able to
be able to inspire someone and help them
out in difficult times
the world can still surprise you with
its kindness but what is no surprise is
that is our show and it was another good
one if I do say so myself I know it
brightened your day I know it lifted you
up we do it we designed it to do so I'm
gonna find some more good stories I'll
see you next time
[Music]